[Music]
there's a lot of girl power tonight I'm
expecting you to bring it for the guys
I'm just here to support the women and
I'm gonna jump up there and try to do my
thing but it's a pretty amazing lineup
females tonight talk about your
performance tonight how do you keep it
fresh well this is my 10th year so 10
years from the first time that I came
here with my brothers and so I did have
a moment little emotional mother last
night but I kind of said I'm really
grateful that I'm still here still the
mix and that they asked me to perform
this year so I'm thinking myself we'll
find you right after Demi takes down the
house we're sorry not sorry amazing good
night
tonight is the first night that Selena's
gonna perform after her big surgery
nerves and you know how do you go into
that there's lot of pressure on her I
wouldn't be able to speak on what she's
feeling which is going through but I can
say that it's amazing to see what she's
what she's done what she's gone through
and I think we were all you know in
supporting her and showing it sending
her all the love in the world where that
all happened I think she's gonna be
amazing tonight
now I love that you told us that how you
knew sort of that your brother Joe had
found his person what will you do
special at the wedding like will you
sing well there'll be a choreographed
dance how does he choose a best man
because there's two brothers I mean I
think my brother Kevin when he got
married he had all of us be the best man
that's kind of the diplomatic approach
but I don't know it's up to him if he
wants me to sing I'll sing but I kind of
want to just be able to enjoy the night
and dance my last thing Diana Ross is
performing tonight
how did she influence you there's some
funk in your music so I know that she
was she inspired you my dad raised us on
some great music Diana Ross being one of
those great artists it's incredible to
see her up here on the stage and I
actually soundcheck right before her
last night was kind of taking off in the
corner someone's like you wanna go say
hi I was like I can't
oh not I think you are you can go see
our backseat
I'll go say hi
[Music]
you
[Music]